j'ai
[Musique]
décidé de sortir de ma
Bastille
est elle c'est Colette originaire de
Versailles elle a tout quitté pour sa
passion la musique inspirée par la
chanteuse québécoise Charlotte cardan et
des groupes de rock anglais des années
70-80 elle exprime ses sentiments avec
douceur et audace cette paix c'est
vraiment la ça raconte vraiment
l'histoire d'une émancipation et de
d'une découverte de soi qui part d'un
endroit où c'est vraiment pas où je je
me connaissais vraiment pas beaucoup et
donc ça a été une gros un gros travail
d'introspection pour découvrir quelles
étaient mes failles mais les choses sur
lesquelles je devais travailler pour me
rapprocher de moi-même en juin dernier
elle sort son premier single peur de
l'amour une consécration pour Colette
qui touche petit à petit à son rêve avec
la musique elle s'est réinventé bien
pouvoir le faire sans savoir aimer au
grand jour que faire apparaître
sincère Colette elle est assez
parisienne j'ai pas mal vécu à Paris
donc je pense que c'est pour ça que ça
Emprin de ça
elle est assez parisienne elle est
timide mais en même temps elle a envie
d'être vu donc c'est tout est assez
contradictoire en fait chez Colette je
pense que c'est sa timidité qui lui
demande de faire ça mais elle a surtout
envie de dévoiler ses émotions son
prochain EP devrait sortir dans le
courant du mois de mars en attendant la
chanteuse vient de publier son nouveau
titre j'avance je suis tout est son
contraire où sont passés mes
repères même si les opposés s'attirent
dans ma tête ils se repousent
Colette vous entraîne dans ses
expériences passées avec panache et
candur laissez-vous transporter par
cette ode à la
liberté